how's it going bros my name is Phelan
[Applause]
welcome to black forest version two I
have not played version while but we
wake up in a bed probably just
masturbating just saying alright let's
check hearing all these got a lute [ __ ]
for this first thing you do let you
pause it
pick up your clothes pick up your carpet
and let's go shock chop some milk all
right let's go carpet gotta go buy milk
hey this looks familiar I don't trust
this I bought you mr. carbon why aren't
you answering me some mr. carbon why
it's a carbon table talking I don't
understand I don't I can't undress them
huh no I can't they're glued oh wait oh
what's going on here I didn't know that
hello pity you're dead you're so screwed
you can't untrust us anymore see I'm
just oh okay that's not going there
that's bad door
what you got here that's pretty nice oh
why don't I sleep in here this is much
better
enjoying some way now you missed a shirt
yeah very nice you crave a knife with
wine and you know the fire I could burn
no but you got to take it easy
I'm a shirt camo activated poop all
right let's take out the tinderbox no oh
oh mr. chef Tommy pips Shan mode
activated Jesus Christ don't pick me up
you could see you
alright I'm gonna check for you and then
share more activate Boop where is he I
don't trust I know I know there's
something wrong with you I don't yeah I
don't trust you did you see this mr.
Karpe red carpet why aren't you talking
to me seriously though did I do
something wrong don't look at me like
that mr. carpet I don't understand all
right
okay we good I think why are you looking
at
okay check this door out
yeah pretty cozy actually are put this
here it's kind of [ __ ]
alright by boxes get there I found a
cigarette I know I [ __ ] net alright
oh it was you wasn't it barrels okay
yeah come on pick it up dude
alright let's go oh hey caramel heavy
okay I think we're good I don't Cristo's
I don't trust you and I don't trust you
hey do you have trusted yourself I don't
like when you trust himself alright fine
fine
skin I don't care hello what's going on
in here
where's the phone oh where is he who's
hiding him from me
I don't want that stupid map I want the
key wine stain ek safar I must have left
it there for me
I'll get the help Rara all right no all
right again
fine battles secrets no I don't even
know all right let's go here ah it's
locked
maybe here no probably here okay wait
what does the general say only eggs rock
need to find a way in another way fart
what nah
alright fine fine I don't need your help
stupid game I hate games I mean I know
what gave me be here yeah okay
oh why look this is not why this is very
nice delay I am momentum become very
nice yeah we we I is not look good okay
is knowledge barrels I made it be
careful okay we're good Wow either bells
everywhere why are you holding the
castle castle really I mean battles stop
hide it from me
nothing forget Wigan
no no just Oh Giggy fine
are you stomach bugs in the air mouse
did you put the box there you [ __ ]
down Oh cause it pause it pause it pause
it
huh boxes yep we get I think he knows
where I am
that ass right damn girl nothing went my
way there everything Oh still out there
not yep he's still out there
he watched me but it's tears without
that ash like he's been working out for
sure like bad eggs tonight I tried brush
their sizes not AG is he brought you got
a new like squeeze and then release he
does that for a living holy [ __ ] he's
good he's still out there
these guys cut me a break
oh [ __ ] it's so dark
I don't have anything let's go home
buddy
go
is she going all right
Oh sweets in the box well why did I
light that up
I don't mean to click why isn't he going
away oh how many is it [ __ ] go home
buddy
huh oh cool no no no open the door for
me
Boober Boober Boober open the frame
oh okay let's go and open the door yep
you read a buddy
bro bro open the door okay good job bro
good job stupid bro man he's such an
idiot
oh no don't come back bro I'm not here
Foxy's over there go yes yes yes yes yes
ah stupid son of a [ __ ] I got away so
easily
Jesus crazy stupid Oh No how is it
possible
[Applause]
what waiter I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
yep the other I'm gonna go yeah back in
the cradle yep yeah back in the castle
going back sorry bro
Lana Atlanta would praise feet right now
oh [ __ ] I thought it was that no no no
ma'am
nan Madol back don't tell me is in here
as a possible crowbar Oh looks good a
little script stop stop
sit I'm bagging that Boas hiding we call
it come on it came out of Carly
I get it I get you getting I got okay
[Applause]
I'm a leg twisted my leg
how do we get it down I'm gonna go back
there but laughs okay very good
I got robot bells don't you dare [ __ ]
tell me where I am him well how swear to
God I [ __ ] kill you oh damn this
valve is freaking crazy
Rose I think I'm gonna end it there like
a favorite and all I can't stuff and
I'll be sure to make more right now okay
[Music]
Oh do something